all right everybody I think we're ready
to start thank you for coming to NDC
Oslo this is the first talk of the day
there's going to be functional
programming talks in this room all day
long and tomorrow as well and Friday as
well so if you're interested in
functional programming just stay in this
room all day long and there is also a
functional lab which i think is going to
be in room 10 kind of going outside and
then going up where we're gonna launch
time so if you have any questions about
functional programming you can come and
talk to people like me and Tomas and
Matthias and so on right let's start so
this talk is the power of composition
it's a talk for beginners in functional
programming so if you're already
familiar with function programming this
is probably not very interesting to you
I have a website f-sharp on a profit so
I'm very into a sharp and we have an
f-sharp consulting business if your
interest is and that's so thought
beginners an FP I'm going to be using F
sharp which is a functional language but
the concepts will work in most
programming languages except maybe COBOL
or something so it's really about the
principles behind functional programming
and composition in particular people who
took going about composition a lot in
functional programming and I just
thought I'd have a talk which tells you
what they mean so I'm going to start off
by talking about the philosophy of
composition and then I'll talk about
functional programming principles
because this is a beginners tour so
functions and how to compose them types
and how to compose them and then we'll
actually get into some meat and we'll
actually look at composition in practice
we'll start with two really simple
examples and then we'll do fizzbuzz
we'll do a kind of really complicated
version of fizzbuzz just for fun and
then we'll talk about the whole monad
things and then I'll demonstrate how you
can actually build a web service using
composition so no objects anywhere no
objects were harmed in this talk so
let's start with philosophy okay so in
order to understand composition you have
to have been a child at some point and
the reason is
because you have to played with a lego
and hopefully everyone here has played
with Lego and hopefully everyone here is
also playing with toy trains so this is
going to be very important and you'll
see why in a minute
and in fact you actually don't have to
have been a child at some point because
it turns out there's a lot of adults who
really like playing with Lego too so if
you google a foal eagle adult Friends of
Lego there's a whole world of adult Lego
people there so what is the lego
philosophy so Lego philosophy all pieces
are designed to be connected to each
other and if you connect any two pieces
you get another kind of piece that could
be connected to other kinds of pieces
and the pieces are reusable in many
different contexts so let's go into that
a bit more here's some Lego and you can
see every single piece a little bumps on
it alright they're all design every
piece is designed to be connected right
there's no pieces which you can't
connect and if you connect two pieces
together you get another kind of piece
so you start off with one thing and you
put a piece on it and that gives you
another kind of bigger piece that you
can glue things on top of and then you
can take that bigger piece and glue
things on top of that and so on and so
on until you've made something and
what's cool is you don't need a special
kind of adapter to glue things to
connect things you can just they're
designed to be connected inherently you
can just literally touch things together
you know put things together and they
work and you can keep adding and adding
until you make a really big thing like
this okay so this is a giant piece of
Lego and it's not finished you can add
things to this too if you had enough
pieces you know alright so this thing of
adding and adding and making bigger
things out of small things that is the
whole principle of composition now
there's something else important which
is if the pieces are reusable what they
don't just make one kind of thing you
know you can build a plane out of them
and then you can take the same pieces
apart and we use them in a different
context okay they're designed to be
reusable they're not designed you can't
just make a plane and then never use
them for anything else okay they're
designed to be generic reusable pieces
and that means they have no strings
attached
because if they had little strings
attached you know you wouldn't be able
to like take them apart and reuse them
because they'd be the strings would get
tangled together literally right so mean
if Lego if each Lego piece had a power
cable
you know you'd end up with some sort of
horrible mess like this so the very fact
that LEGO pieces don't have power cables
they don't have strings they don't
depend on anything outside the piece the
pieces are completely self-contained all
right there's a really important
principle because if they weren't
self-contained they wouldn't be reusable
they wouldn't be composable so there's
the power composition with Lego now we
can do the same thing with wooden
railway tracks so I'm sure you've all
played with Brio or something like this
again all the pieces are designed to be
connected you can connect pieces
together and they're reusable so here's
some wooden railway track and they're
designed to be connected because every
single piece has a little bump in it
just like Lego right and you can
literally glue them together you get a
bigger piece of track okay you don't
need special adapters you just literally
do that no special adapters needed and
because of that you can keep adding and
adding and adding until you make a
really big thing so there's a big thing
made some smaller things and there's the
power of composition this whole thing of
gluing things makings starting with
small things gluing them together to
make bigger things I'm going to go on
and on and on the power curbs I'm going
to say that over and over because that's
the title of this talk the power of
composition compels me to say the power
of composition alright again they're
reusable you can make one little layer
and then you can take it apart and make
another layer okay this is obvious I
mean if you couldn't do this these toys
wouldn't be fun right the whole reason
why these toys are fun to play with why
Lego is great and one way wouldn't wear
always of great is because they're fun
you can like you know do something and
take it apart do something else all
right let's move on to programming so
the UNIX philosophy is actually very
very similar and I stole this form the
Wikipedia article so don't blame me you
notice if I don't get this right so
white programs that do one thing well
that's one of the philosophies
and if you need to do something new
start a new piece you don't complicate
old programs by adding new features each
piece is a little small thing that does
one thing well and then you write
programs to work together which means
that you design your programs to expect
input from programs you don't even know
about you expect them to be working in a
bigger system so you designed to work
with input and output and then finally
you make them use text streams because
that's the universal interface well
that's maybe not the best universal
interface but it's a pretty good
interface here certainly was pretty good
for the 1970s when UNIX was design so
this Maps very well to our composition
philosophy you know the pieces are
reusable the pieces are designed to be
connected and they don't need any
adapters you don't need a special kind
of adapter when you're piping things
between unix components all right no
special adapters needs so this is the
UNIX philosophy is a philosophy all
about composition which is why again
it's very very popular okay so that's
enough philosophy let's talk about
functional programming so functional
programming and I can say this is but
you know things I'm just going to go
through some very basic stuff about
functional programming a couple of core
principles so the first core principle
of functional programming is it's all
about functions functions or things and
I'm going to use the analogy of a little
bit of railway track like this the
second important principle of functional
programming is to use composition
everywhere so you don't have objects you
don't have variables you don't have all
that so if you just have functions and
you glue them together composition just
like Lego and the final thing is if
you're coming from a an oo background
the types in a statically typed
functional programming language like F
sharp or Haskell or Scala or something
types are not the same thing of classes
okay they're sort of more like sets and
arias I'll demonstrate well then what I
mean by that in a minute so let's start
with functions so a function like I say
is I like to think of it as a little bit
of railway track
and it transforms inputs to outputs
there's a little tunnel on this and
there's railway track and it's the
tunnel of transformation so something
comes in one side like an apple and it
comes out the other side and it gets
turned into a banana okay so this is a
very simple function that turns apples
into bananas and in functional
programming you tend to write this Apple
our banana that's how I would indicate
what the function does so very important
that functions are standalone things
they're not attached to a class they're
not methods they're standalone things
and what's it why that's really
important is that by the way and
standalone is just another word for
reusable right stand-alone means you can
reuse it so there's no strings attached
so because it's a standalone thing it
can be used as inputs and outputs of
other functions and let's look at some
examples of that
so here is a here's a function with an
input and here is the output being
another function or here is a standalone
function and it's got a regular output
but the input is another function
alright that okay or here is a
standalone function and it's got a
regular input now but but there's a
parameter which is a function and that
parameter can be used to control how the
function works for example
so having functions as inputs and
functions and outputs and functions and
parameters that's a very simple
principle but you can actually build
really complicated systems from that a
way of doing things for example you can
have a function that returns a function
that generates other functions that have
passed a promise that you know you can
really big complex things but the
fundamental principle is pretty
straightforward and we'll see an example
of a function that returns of functions
surely so that's the first principle
functions these things so we haven't
talked about classes we haven't talked
about objects all we've got is functions
now the second thing is you've got all
these functions how do you build things
from the functions well the answer is
composition so here's how a function
composition works you have two functions
one that takes an apple to a banana
one that takes a banana to a cherry say
and you want to glue them together to
make a bigger function well I think it's
pretty obvious how you glue them
together you literally take the output
of one and you stick it into the end put
the other right so you take these two
things and you kind of smush them
together and now you have a new function
all right that's before that's after
hopefully that's kind of common sense
it's really obvious how you do this it's
just like the the model railway track
what's interesting about this new
function though is that you can't tell
that it was built from small functions
there's no seams in particular where did
the banana go right the other work
functions had bananas this function
doesn't have any bananas anywhere so you
kind of you've got data hiding you've
got abstraction already so when I'm
giving you this function you don't you
don't know about bananas all you care is
about apples and cherries and you can
repeat you know you can take this thing
and glue it to another function that
uses cherries and hide the cherries so
you know the fact that the level of the
function doesn't matter you don't know
where this is a high-level function of a
small level think they're all exactly
the same functions just functions so a
very important point though is an order
for function composition to work they
have to be self-contained functions with
no strings attached just like a Lego
right if they've got strings attached
you can't glue them together because
they get tangled up so what does strings
attached mean in terms of programming
well it means that data has to be
immutable because if you change the data
inside a function you know you're
messing with stuff it's a function minor
ways the order of the functions they
used makes a difference for example
there's no side-effects that's another
way of saying us it's not changing
anything in the outside world there's no
input or output that you're not writing
to the file system you're not writing to
a database you're not messing there with
global variables so that does restrict
the kinds of things you can do with pure
functions there are ways around this
which we'll talk about but in basically
if you have these friends of pure
functions you can compose them really
nicely right this no strings will
attached will is really important and
Fat Joe Armstrong who created Erlang has
a whole famous quote about this he said
I think the lack of reusability comes in
object oriented languages not in
functional languages why is that the
prom with object languages they've got
all this implicit environment they carry
around with them you wanted a banana but
what you got was the gorilla holding the
Minar and you got the entire jungle so
this is the thing if you've ever tried
to refax
refactor a complex object you know you
can't just pull the method out because
the method depends on a local variable
and the local variable depends on
something that was dependency injected
and the thing that was a dependency
injected depends on something else is
like yes sometimes it's really hard to
refactor because there's all this
implicit things going on in objects and
in in functions there's no implicit
everything is explicitly passed in and
explicitly comes out there's no kind of
mysterious side-effects there's no
strings attached alright so that's
competition let's look at a real example
let's say we have an add one function
and a double function okay in an f-sharp
would write like this add 1 equals x
plus 1 double equals x plus 6 very
simple and we just use this little
double angle bracket that's the
composition thing so I just take these
two functions like smush them together
and I get a new function add one and
then double it so in pictures we've
gauged we've taken these two things
we've smush them together we have a new
function and we can just call it like it
was not any other function we just say
if we pass 5 to it we get 12 for example
so we can't tell that this function was
built from smaller functions and if we
have three functions we can smash them
all together add 1 then double it then
square it
when the iteration machine put together
with a composition and then we've got a
new function we just call it if we call
it with 5 we get 144 so that's
composition in practice is pretty simple
now there's another way of doing
composition which is actually much more
common in F sharp and it's called piping
and the reason why piping is this is
because calling functions with
parameters can often get really messy so
let's say we call add 1 with 5 ok but
then we want to double it and then we
want to square it we end up with this
kind of nested parentheses
you know and it's very hard sometimes
when it's really nested to find out
where exactly to start from you know you
have to start from the middle and what
kind of work your way up so that can be
kind of confusing so an alternative way
of doing this is that you kind of start
with one thing it's the piping model
just like UNIX piping you start with one
thing you take five and you pass it to
add one and that gives you six and you
take the output of add one and you pass
it a double
and that gives 12 and you take the
output of double and you pass it to
square and that makes 144 so you're just
taking this number and you're taking it
into one function taking the output
passing the next one taking the output
posting this on exactly like UNIX pipes
and this is actually a lot easy to
understand and you'll see this all the
time and in functional programming and
so an f-sharp we have this pipe symbol
which is a vertical bar with an angle
bracket the vertical bar is on its own
is used for something else so it's it's
almost like the UNIX pipe symbol but not
exactly the same okay so we're going to
be using pipes every time you see that
in the Reston's talk that's what it is
it's the pipe symbol pipes everywhere
alright so now that we've got
composition of two functions let's see
how it can build an entire application
from functions okay its composition all
the way up so let's say we have a couple
of low-level operations like you know
upper casing a string so application
your string is a pure function you pass
in a string and you get another string
back so you know it's pretty obvious
it's a function now if you take these
low-level operations and you glue them
together you might get a kind of a
bigger set of things called maybe a
service okay so address validation
service for example and you pass in an
address and you get backers on a
validation result and for people under
30 I just have to explain what services
it's just like a micro service but
without service in front yeah the
services of our old-fashioned words
right so we got these services we're
glue them together and we do them
they're there in two sawsan are you or a
use case or
whatever you want to call it they say
update your customer data or whatever
you're passing a requests you get back a
result and by the way this is not the
quest response
this is input/output this is a subtly
different approach then oh oh so you're
not you're not passing you're not
sending a message and getting a message
back you have an input and output the
railway track model okay you take all
these use cases and you build them into
a web application so the web application
has some sort of HTTP input has some
sort of outputs and inside the web
application you basically have a
controller or a dispatcher or whatever
you want to call it that decides which
one of these things to run based on the
request that comes in and will actually
see an example of how to do this at the
end of this talk and notice I haven't
had there's no objects all right you say
well how can I do this without objects
they weren't any object you'll see in
the in the final example there there's
no objects anywhere it's all just
functions say what's interesting about
this thing about composition is it's a
kind of fractal self-similar kind of
thing you know that you use exactly the
same techniques to compose big things as
you used to compose small things it's
just like the Lego again gluing to beat
LEGO pieces together and gluing to
massive Lego things together it's the
same exactly the same kind of principle
and if you had a kind of a complex web
app this is what it would look like
there'd be all these little functions
inside and that'd be you know routed or
routed through through those functions
based on the the request on the response
so this is what a functional app looks
like and that is the power of
composition I have to say it again right
so power composition with with the
railway power composition with Lego and
you know all the other kinds of power
composition we're going to talk about
now functional programs love composition
so much that they have all this jog and
around it and there's a lot of jharkhand
that you'll hear which is really if you
think about it just ways of making
composition easier it will make a lot
more sense so if you sample you'll hear
the word
noise and that is really just a way of
combining things like strings and lists
and functions even you combine two
things to make another one of the same
kinds there's typically called amyloid
monads another big buzzword in
functional programming and monads is all
about how can you compose things which
have effects not necessarily
side-effects but that happen that have
more than one output and we'll actually
see an example with the fizzbuzz later
on and finally category theory
functional programmers love to talk
about category theory and one of the
reasons is because you can sort of think
of category theory as composition
theories it's like what happens if I
take this thing and I connected this
thing is that the same thing as if I
connect this things of this thing you
know it's about composition it's not
really about composition Burton and when
I'm going to hope no mathematicians
actually listening to this I apologized
other mathematicians but it's good
enough for it for you right okay final
principle for functional programming is
that types are not classes okay more
like sets so if a type isn't a class
what is it so if you think of our
function it has an input and output and
the type is just a name for a set of
things so here's all the set of valid
inputs for this function and here's the
set of valid outputs for this function
so we just give these set of valid
inputs instead of an A now just give it
a name so for example if this function
can take any possible integer oh these
set of numbers we call that that set
type integer go into 32 whatever if it
can return any you know sequence of
characters we say that's type string if
we can take it any kind of person we say
this of type person but it's lit it's
not the same thing as they as a class
it's just a literally a list of all the
people in the world conceptually list of
all the people in the world that's give
that set a named person okay there's no
behavior it's just a set and here's an
example of a set of fruits and it
because it's just a set of course you
can have a set of functions so this is a
set of functions which turn food into
fruits this is the fruit - fruit
functions
and we give that a name we call it food
to fruit functions you know so because
it's just a set it's nothing special now
because they're just sets types can be
composed and we call this an algebraic
type system or I'd rather call it a
composable type system because you can
glue types together to make bigger types
and that is only possible because types
don't have behavior right behavior is
done separately from from the types and
because it's just sets of things you can
do set Union you can do set intersection
you can do what kind of thing these new
sets and make bigger sets so in an
algebraic type system you build new
types some smaller types to possible
ways one is you add them together and
the other is C or them together so what
do I mean by that so when you add things
together you might say well you know to
make a fruit salad I need an apple and a
banana and a cherry so those are the
three things I need and and I need all
of them and this is typically called you
know record who are tuple so an f-sharp
would write like this we say a fruit
salad
here's an apple and a banana and a
cherry and this is you know so you can
see it's kind of got feel sort of like
JavaScript and that the type of Apple is
an apple varieties of itself is a type
of all the possible apples in the world
so that's a record type in their shop
with curly braces now the other kind of
way of composing types together is
something you don't get in c-sharp and
Java which is oaring them together so if
I want a snack I could say well I want
an apple or a banana or cherry just one
not not all of them at the same time
just pick one of those three so this is
a kind of thing you can't really do is
sort of like an e none in c-sharp and
java is not exactly the same and in F
sharp would write like this a snack is
either apple or banana or cherry and of
course with each thing there's a type
that goes on if it's an Apple is the set
of all possible apples it could be if
it's banana is set for Bernard as it
could be so I call that a choice type in
F sharp is called a discriminated union
you sometimes hear them called some
types and so on
so that's very very important type and
we'll see why it's really useful the
minute so here's a real-world example
let's say that you have some sort of
payment processing system and you accept
three kinds of payment like cash checks
and credit cards now for cash there's no
extra information associated with it the
checks we need a check number and for
credit cards we need a credit card type
and a card number right so how would you
implement this in your language of
choice well if you were using an oo
language like C sharp or Java
you'd probably kind of start with an
interface like a payment method
interface would have some methods on it
or something and then you'd say well
cash is a kind of subclass or in you
know inherits or implements that
interface and then you'd have another
subclass or check and you'd have another
subclass for credit cards and so on so
that all implement a particular
interface or would inherit from a
particular abstract base class that's
kind of our way of doing it's all about
the behavior each interface has its own
behavior now in F sharply pulley
wouldn't do it this way we would compose
types like this so it start off with
some primitive types like a check number
is just an INT a card number is just a
string and so on so forth we take these
basic concepts and we build bigger ones
from the smaller ones so we'd say a card
type is a choice this is a choice type
between a Visa and MasterCard and a
credit card information is a is a record
it's an and so we say it's a card type
and a card number okay so it's a record
so there's a choice type to make a
bigger thing and a record type to make a
bigger thing okay now we've got these
things now we build stuff on top of that
we say welcome payment method is a
choice it's a choice between cash and
check and if it's cheque we need the
information from the check number we
define above and if it's a credit card
we need the information from the credit
card that we define above so we're
building on top of the types you defined
earlier and that's a choice type and
then we can build on top of that and we
can say well okay a payment mount is a
decimal that's a primitive currency is a
choice between euros and dollars say
okay another choice type another
primitive type and then we can build an
even bigger type say your payment's is
an amount
it's a record is an amount and it's a
currency and it has a method so it's a
payment and and each one of those in
turn the amount is a payment amount or
the payment amount was defined earlier
the payment method was defined as the
choice type
so we've building a bigger and bigger
set of types from a very small initial
set of primitives and you can keep going
going you can now make the payment part
of an order or an invoice or something
and you can then make the order by no
because you can just keep building
building bigger and bigger types from
this basic process okay so record types
which are an types and choice types
which are all types so bigger type some
smaller types that's the power of
composition okay you've heard it before
now what's cool about doing this with
the types is you get kind of executable
documentation which is something we kind
of always go forward to to have the
documentation as part of the code so if
I showed you this codes if suit is a
club or a diamond or a spade or heart
and a rank is a 2 or 3 or 4 or so on a
card is a suit and a rank a hand is a
list of cards a deck is as cards a
player is a name and a hand and a game
is a deck and a list a place so this is
all executable code but it's you know I
think you can guess what I'm talking
about here without having to look in 20
different files we look at we know the
doc 200 200 page requirements
documenting something this is very nice
so we've got using types here to
represent nouns but we can also put
function types in there so we can say to
deal you start with a deck that's the
input and you output a new pair you bout
put a new deck because the deck is
immutable so when you've taken a card
off the dick you have a different deck
with one less card and now you also have
a card on the table so the output is a
card on the table and a smaller deck or
to pick up a card off the table
you start off with your hand and there's
a card on the table that's the input and
after you've picked up your card you now
have a bigger hand and there's
card on the table so you can actually
represent verbs with types as well so
this is pretty cool we've actually
represented the entire domain on one
screen so it's not scattered around in
20 different files like you might have
an inner in c-sharp achar it's literally
on one screen which is very useful if
you're trying to do domain driven design
and you want a domain expert to kind of
go through this with you because if it's
a main expert looks as this thicket
actually even though they're not a
program where they could look at this
they actually you missed out you know I
kind of seat maybe you need Joker in
there or something and you forgot about
it so here's a more real-world example
if I show some of this code and I say
what payment methods do we take
can you guess what payment methods we
take it's pretty obvious you just look
down this list yeah we take three you
don't have to look in the documentation
that sort of dig down to the coders is
really obvious so typically in a
functional program you'd have something
like this as the sort of first file in
your program and if define the domain
for the rest of the system and so this
is code but it's also documentation if
you change this the rest of the code
won't compile and you'll have to fix it
up so this is a massive topic if you're
interested in DDD and designing the
types I have a whole talk on that on my
website and I also have a whole book
about this if you're interested domain
modeling made functional which is
available in the bookstore right here
and if you want to get a signed copy
come and grab me right okay so that's
enough theory let's talk about some real
codes so start with a very very simple
example which is think of a number so
this is the children's game think of a
number where you say think of a number
add one square it subtract 1 divided by
than we first thought of subtract the
number you first thought of and the
answer is 2 it's not amazing absolutely
incredible I don't know how this works
so anyway so this is let's implement
this ok so we're going to use this
composition idea we're going to have
each little piece is going to be a
little bit of well we track you and
we're gonna glue the well we try
together so we're going to start with a
number you thought of going to feed into
the first one which adds one and we're
taking the output of that and feed it
into the track 1 take the output of that
feed it into square it and so on and so
forth until we get the final answer
okay so this is the design we're going
to use so let's actually look at the
code so we're going to define little
helper functions for each step so to add
one we just add one to square it we
square it you subtract one you know we
subtract 1 2 divided by number you
thought off we do that so we're going to
define all these little helper functions
these are the fill bits of railway track
and then once we've got the help of
functions we can just do the piping
thing we start with a number we feed it
into add 1 we take the app put a bad one
and feed into square it we take the
output a square it feed it into the
tracks or take the output of that and so
on and so on
and that gives us the final answer which
is 2 so this is a complete little
program written using nothing but
functions ok it's object free code
alright ok this is a very kind of
trivial example so we'll look at some
more complicate but it gives you an idea
of how you might write something using
nothing but functions and composition so
I hope this makes sense all right
ok it's not always that easy of course
it's a very trivial example so what
we've got here is we've got got two
functions each with one input and one
output and we glue them together and we
get a new function and everything is
good and everything is very easy and
there's no problems but of course the
real world is never that easy
so let's look at a couple of challenges
the first thing is what happens if you
have a function with two outputs right
instead of one output all right some
functions more complicating that some
functions have two inputs right they're
not always one input one output so if
you have a function with one output and
two inputs how can you believe them
together all right it's like it seems
like it'd be impossible to do that so
that's our first challenge what happens
if it's got two outputs and one input
how do you glue those together that
seems pretty hard as well so that'll be
our second challenge and we'll look at
both of these challenges in the rest of
the talk so let's start with the first
one composing multiple inputs with Roman
numerals so two Roman numerals to make
something into Roman numerals this is
our little task we take an integer like
5 and we turn it into Roman numerals
which we and to me is a V
and so you know 12 would be x11 or
whatever like that okay so hopefully
everyone's familiar with how this works
so that here's the design with any years
we're gonna face the design on the fact
that Roman numerals are based on a tally
system you might make four marks and
when you have the fifth mark you put a
line through all right and hopefully
maybe that's where the V came from I'm
not sure but it's a tally system so
we're going to do is if you want to
convert say 17 into Roman numerals we're
gonna make 17 copies of what of the I
bet alerted I okay 17 eyes and then
every time you see five eyes in a row we
will paste it with a V and every time
you see two V 0 will face with an X and
every time we see five X's Noel will
place it with an L and every time you
see two L's we replace it with a c so
this is a very very simple
implementation nothing complicated about
it and I want to say it's highly
performant but it's probably good enough
for what we need but it's a really
simple model for for the design okay and
we keep going and going going depending
how high you want to get so again we
have these little bits of rail will the
way we're going to do it is a little bit
of railway track we're gonna start by
replicating it however many times and
then we're going to replace five eyes
with a V and a place to visa the X and
place five X's with an L and so on and
so forth all right so that's the design
here's the problem is through a place
function that we use it has three inputs
you have the original input string and
you have the old value on the new value
and that gives you your new output so a
place is a three input function all
right and that's a problem because we
can't compose you know something with
one output with something wishes with
three inputs all right so this is this
is not good so all the all the
composition patterns we talked about
really only work for functions which
have one parameter if you have more than
one parameter they don't work so that's
that's like bad news right well the good
news is that every function can be
turned into one parameter function it's
one of the key things about functional
programming you can always do this and
this is a technique called currying
named after Haskell curry
and carrying sounds really complicated
but what it really is is just taking a a
two parameter function and turning it
into a one parameter function that
returns another one parameter function
so after carrying we have our function
which has one input not two and instead
of spitting out the answer it spits out
another function this is this whole
thing of functions as inputs and outputs
so the output of this thing is another
function with one input so now we have a
series of one input functions the first
function takes one input spits out a new
function the second function also takes
one input and spits out the final result
so by having a two parameter function
we've now turned it into a series of
every single thing is are now one
parameter function it's a really
important point in getting your head
around functional programming it sounds
more complicated is it's actually pretty
straightforward
but there you go so let's actually look
at it in practice so because of carrying
every function can be turned into a one
argument function and which means we can
use these composition techniques so
here's a replace which is three
parameters so here's the original
version we have three parameters and
naught when we return it and so three
inputs in there three inputs in the code
all right so that's how you might write
it in something like c-sharp and we just
return the string but what instead what
we're going to do is do this we're going
to have a two input function and it's
going to return a lambda okay so it's
got two inputs and the lamp is going to
be returns and the lambda sort of has
the the old value in the user list of
baked into it right so the lambda is a
one parameter function so there's two
inputs for the thing right there's only
two inputs in the actual code and the
lounder itself is now one parameter
function so by doing this we can get at
one parameter function which we can then
compose together okay so once you have
these curried functions you can sort do
the opposite and do something called
partial application very important
technique in functional programming so
that kind of think of it it's not the
same thing as caring at all it's of the
opposite so we have this
to parameter function and what we're
going to do is pass in those two
parameters but not the last parameter
all right so the the replace function
has three inputs originally we're gonna
pass in two of them and bake them in and
the final input we're not gonna pass in
all right
so for example if we want to replace 3/5
eyes with a V we're gonna say replace
five eyes with a V but the actual final
third parameter we're not going to pass
in right now we're going to pass that in
later on when we actually know it is we
don't know what the actual input string
is but we know that the two of the
parameters but we don't know the third
one so we're passing two of them for now
and we'll leave the third one for later
so that's a function so when you call
this we're getting a function now which
is all it's missing is one extra
parameter
similarly if we say replace two reasons
an X we can pass in the two V's and we
can pass in the X the final parameter
which is the string we want to replace
we don't know where that is but now we
have a function that we can actually use
later one okay so only two parameters
are being passed in like that so if we
go back to our design each of our steps
is now one parameter function and the to
the things we're going to replace with
us often are baked in to our steps okay
each little bit of railway track has the
has the replaced parameter sort baked
into it so now we do have a series of
one parameter functions and we can
compose them so here we go we're going
to define our helper functions right and
then once we've got our helper functions
we can say replicate it however many
times do the replace do the replaced is
of a place to the place and so on and
again with our helper functions we're
passing in two out of the three
parameters and the third parameter is
going to be passed in as part of this
piping process all right now one thing
is just rather than defining all these
helper functions and it's much more
common just to like define them in line
so if we something if I want to add two
to something you know add is a two
parameter function but I can say just
add one you know part in one parameter
and then have this second parameter
passed in through piping so for example
when I say add two
it's missing a parameter that extra
parameter is gonna be passed in through
the pipe which is five in this case so
this is going to be five plus two and
then we're going to pass that in to
multiply now multiply again is a two
parameter function we're going to give
it one of the parameters which is the
two and the second parameter is going to
be coming from the pipe so that goes
there's a same as five a two is 10 or a
5 out of 7 times 2 is 14 or okay so if
we look at our code we don't have to
have all this helper functions we
literally just inline the replace like
this so this is our final example and
how we really promote it what's cool
about writing code like this is that you
might have noticed that we actually
don't have a very complete
implementation because in modern Roman
numerals you know if you don't you don't
have five eye for eyes in a row you
place it with one V and you don't have V
one one one one one you have one x so we
can easily add new segments so we can
just say okay every time you see V 1 1 1
I'm just placing 1 X every time you see
four ones just replace it with one V and
so on so this is our final this is our
final implementation this this pipeline
pressure is really nice spoon so you can
slot things in and out of the pipeline
you can add things you can move things
you can add new features at the end just
like the UNIX philosophy okay so that's
this challenge of how do you deal with
two inputs that was our challenge and I
think we have dealt with that
successfully using partial application
so this is why partial application is
really important as a way of helping
with composition all right another one
fist buzz ok so Fitz buzz for people who
aren't familiar with it print the
numbers from 1 200 but if it's a
multiple 3 print fizz if it's multiple
fine print buzz and if it's both print
fizzbuzz multiple 15 okay so here's a
basic implementation if the number
students by 15 print fizzbuzz if it's
divisible by 3
print fears mister visible by 5 print
buzz and so on and so forth otherwise
you print the original number and we
have this little helper function call is
divisible by it's just as if it's
divisible by you know that's good well
this is a perfectly good implementation
but it's not good enough for us today
because I want to do it in a different
way completely I want to make it a lot
complicated and the way I'm going to
make it more complicated and when he is
a functional approach using a pipeline
so what we're going to do is we're going
to have all these little bits of track
and each one does one case so we're
gonna handle the 15 case we're going to
handle the three case we're gonna handle
the five case and anything that we
didn't handle will be in the final
remaining case so how do we implement
each of these cases well we're going to
handle the case there's two possible
choices for the output either it's what
we call uncarbonated which means nothing
happens right like you passed in two and
nothing happened oh it's carbonated
where you get back a string you get back
up fears of a buzz right so how can you
represent a - two different choices for
the output right two different choices
for the output how we're going to
represent that well we're going to
represent it with a little bit of
railway track but this time we're going
to have two outputs in the well we track
okay so it's going to be an input and
there's going to be two possible outputs
one is the uncarbonated case and the
other is the carbonator case so we're
going to create a new type to represent
these choices it's going to have two
choices going to be choice type with two
cases the first case is is uncarbonated
in which case we have the original
integer or it's carbonated and we have a
string like fizz or bars or something I
am so it's an unprocessed case and a
processed case so that's our type server
we modeling our domain with a choice
type and then we're going to have our
actual handle each case our particular
I'm going to call this function
carbonate okay and if it's divisible by
the thing it's going to be carbonated
and we're going to give it a label and
if it's not divisible by the thing it's
uncarbonated and we just leave it alone
okay so there's the carbonated case and
there's the uncarbonated case all right
so that's our complete design right
there that's everything we need and if
you think this is particularly
complicated it is and this is actually
Ragan wold use this as an example of how
not to do an interview question so if
they ask you to do fizzes an interview
don't give them this answer but I
for technical talk it's kind of a fun
way of showing how to do functional
programming right notice this has three
parameters it has the number like three
the label like frizz and the actual
number that you're going to try not work
with all right three proud of function
pay attention to that all right so let's
actually see this in use so let's say we
take 12 and we pass it into carbonate
three with fins now carbonate three with
phases it's really passing into the
extra parameter is going to come from
the 12 that we've passed in through the
pipeline okay so if you pass 12 into
that it says yes that's differs by three
I'm going to give you a fizz if we pass
10 into that it's going to say no no no
that's not divisible by three I'm going
to give you an uncommon age of ten but
if I say if I pass it into carbonate
with five so yeah that does that it does
work and I'm gonna give you a carbonated
buzz okay so there's our little code you
know a little testing our code to make
sure it works okay all right now we have
a problem how do we compose these things
these railway tracks they don't fit
right so what we want to do is if it's
uncarbonated we didn't process that we
want to go on to the next one if it was
Carleton natives we want to bypass we
want to go all the way down once we've
got it carbonated we all go all the way
to the end and not do anything else all
right
so here's the problem how do we compose
these things well the answer is like
this if you've ever played with a toy
train you'll know that you can actually
make two tracks like this so I call this
the two-track model of programming
otherwise known as a railway oriented
programming and I have a whole talk on
this if you're interested and it's a
nice idea in theory but let's see what
the problems are because if you want to
compose one track functions it's really
easy you just take the output of one and
feed it to the input the next one and if
you have to track functions they're easy
to compose too because you take the
output of one thing and connect to that
and you take the output of the second
one and connect to that so that works
fine - no problem composing - to track
functions like this but what we have is
we have a function with one input and
two outputs
and they don't compose all right so this
is our problem this is our challenge so
let's look at our first implementation
we're going to take the result from 15
and if it's carbonated we're done
it was uncarbonated we have to go to the
next step which is try three
if we get three if it's carbonated we're
done if it's uncarbonated we have it to
try five and if that's done if it's
carbonated that works if it's
uncarbonated then we get the final
result so this is an implementation but
it's really really ugly I mean this is a
horrible ugly code but there's a pan we
can make this code a lot simpler if we
notice there's a pattern and the pan is
that every time we have an uncarbonated
case we do something if it's
uncarbonated do something if it's
uncarbonated do something if it's
uncarbonated do something that's the
pattern so let's take that pan and run
with it
so if it's carbonated we're done but if
it's uncarbonated we do something if
that's the pattern we're going to try
and turn into code so we're going to
parameterize what is it we're going to
do what it depends we don't know so
let's write the code if it's uncool this
function if uncarbonated do okay so if
it's a carbon natives we say it's done
if it's uncarbonated we're going to do
something with a number but we don't
know what it is we're going to call the
function with that number where does
that function come from it's going to
come from a parameter so this is
parameterize all the things we don't
know exactly we want to do so we're
going to pass it as a parameter it's a
function parameter fine so it's a
function as a parameter now with this if
uncarbonated do function our code is
actually a lot simpler because we start
with carbonated by 15 if it's
uncarbonated we do we use the carbonate
function with the next one if you're
still on carbonated we do the next one
and if you're still on carbonated that
we do the last step which is slightly
different because we have to do some
special case with other but otherwise we
can keep chaining these steps over and
over and over again so this code is a
lot cleaner it's a lot more linear now
obviously this in if uncommon need to do
is a really weird way of doing fizzbuzz
but you'll see in a minute that is quite
important now one thing one more thing
we said is that we've
fizzbuzz for one number and we wanted it
to work for numbers from one to hundred
now in functional program you're not
allowed to use loops or you can use
loops but generally you don't that won't
work you can't pass a list of numbers
into a functional front with one number
so here we have a function with one
number and what we do is we use another
there's a special thing called a
function transformer which turns
functions into other kinds of functions
and that in this case it's going to be
lists mapped so list map turns a normal
function into functions that work with
lists so after we've done list map we
now have a fizzbuzz that work with lists
and now we can pass in a list of things
as input and get a list of things output
so that's an interesting way of think
about lists map or select in link if you
in fusee shop and you'd use it like this
you say fizzbuzz for list is list map or
fizzbuzz so this map is oh is a function
transformer so here's our final code
carbonate it if I'm company to do this
if I can they do this otherwise do the
last step and to do it from once 100 we
say is 100 we feed it into we feed that
list of numbers into the mapped version
of fizzbuzz and then it gives us another
list of things and then finally we print
those things out so what's another way
and what's interesting about this is
we're only doing the i/o or any printing
things at the very end everything else
is a pure function with no side effects
unlike they're very the first example I
showed you a it printed right in the
middle of the loop this is a much more
reusable kind of code all right and that
brings us to the M word so there's a
general solution to handling functions
like this and the answer is yes and the
answer is bind bind is the answer
bind all the things FP people like the
word bind a lot so we have a very common
problem in function program we have
these kinds of two parameters two things
with two outputs and and they're not
suitable for composition if we could can
turn them into these kind of to track
things they would be suitable for
composition because these things are
very easy to work with all right so
that's good so we have a general problem
of turning the top kind of thing into
the bottom kind of thing and that's what
binders by there's a kind of adapter
block if you think of the Model Railway
again you can kind of have a big block
and you kind of slot the
that the points functional the switch
function into it and you get a new
two-track function see there's a kind of
a slot for a function you pass in the
points and you get back a to track
that's what mind is so here's the
implementation of bind for carbonated so
we pass in two things okay if the input
is uncarbonated then we call this
carbonation function and if the input
was already carbonated then we just
bypass we never call the function okay
and this is exactly what our if
uncarbonated he was right that's exactly
this is exactly the same implementation
as uh if I'm coming in to except this
time we're calling it bind so this
brings us to monads so monad sounds
scary but it's really not as scary as
you might think it's really a monad is
just a datatype and an associated bind
function and a couple of other stuff
which is really not important right now
so is this a datatype in a bind function
so in our case the datatype was the
carbonation results which is that little
thing with the two choices and the bind
function was the if on Carboni to do so
we just created our own monad in the
last few minutes and sometimes you hear
the word monadic function which is a
switch or a points function and then
again used by in to compose them so
there's carbonate the carbonate function
like that that was our monadic functions
that we were working with okay so that's
what a monad is is unfortunately
unfortunate terminology but there you go
that's what we have alright so there's
two outputs one inputs and that was our
challenge number to do how can we close
them we said we've proposed them with
monads all right
one more example of using binds so async
tasks async futures promises tasks
whatever II want to call them you often
will connect them when the task
completes do the next thing
otherwise you're done let's look at some
codes so typically you might say start a
task when it's finished do the next
thing and when it's finished do the next
thing when it's finished do the next
thing and so on so forth you get this
thing called the Pyramid of doom which
is pretty ugly so let's see how monads
can solve this problem so we're going to
have a bind function for task
and it says when finished do something
okay and this thing that you do is a
parameter you don't really care what it
is it's just a function parameter that
you can a person just like we did with
the if I'm culminated so if you take
once we've got this is a bind helper
function we can rewrite that code as
start the task and then bind it to start
another term and bind it to another
start another toss so now instead of
having this kind of pyramidal going
further and further out you just have a
nice linear line of things to do this is
why functional people like monads for
this kind of thing one more example
error generating functions so you often
have a situation way you might have a
website and you have some some inputs
you validate request you canonicalize
the email make it lower case for example
effect your record from the database
update a record in the database and so
on but the problem is there's all sorts
of errors like that the name might not
be there my name might be blank you
might not find the user in the database
you might get an authorization error
there's all these things and go wrong
right so it's not a nice linear thing
you have to have all this error handling
stuff so to model this in functional
away we'd have all these different steps
so the validation step might or might
not work is that it's a kind of a to two
outputs the lower casing an email is
always going to work so there's a one
input one output fetching something from
the database might a mine at work it
might give an error so that's a there's
the two possible outputs and updating
something in the database and might not
return anything at all it just does it
and never returns so these kinds of
functions are not composable the way
they stand so one of the things that
functional programmers do spend a lot of
time making kind these things into
comparable functions since is where the
monads come in so we miss matched as
they are right now but if we use a map
function and we use a bind function and
we use various other things to you know
transform functions into other functions
once we've done the transformation like
this we transform our original functions
into new functions like that and then
once they've been transformed into new
functions these new functions can be
composed so by turning for example
turning the DB fetch in to bind we've
turned it into a two-track function by
using map on the lower case in the email
we've turned it into
function and so on and so forth and once
you've got all these two-track functions
it's really obvious how to clear them
together so again all these things like
Mona's and stuff is really to make about
making composition easier all right
final thing web service so that's one
kind of composition we've talked about
two tracks but another kind of
composition these these monadic
functions these like one track input to
track out but this happen all the time
and there's another way of composing
them other than the two-track model it's
called Heisley composition and what
happens is you take two of these things
and you glue them together
and you get another one of the same kind
so this is just like adding two numbers
together and get another number adding
you know concatenate another list
composing these two kinds of functions
and get another function of the same
kind that's closely a composition okay
very important that's the same kind of
thing this is where this whole concert
of monoids comes in making two glowing
two things together and get the same
kind of thing back so there's this
library called swath IO which is an
f-sharp web library and it has a concept
of a web part and a web part has an
input which is an HTTP context
everything you need to know about the
HTTP the requests and the cookies and
all that stuff okay and the output is an
async of an optional HTTP context so
it's async because it's might not really
know it returns not immediately and it's
optional because you might not handle it
you might say I can't handle this thing
you've given me a get like I can only do
posts so it's got two possible outputs
okay so it might fail right so there's a
whole bunch of things let's look at how
this works in practice so the way you
glue these things in in suave is you
have this composition it supplies the
composition symbol which is an angle
equals an angle you glue two thumbs
together you get another one of the same
kind of thing just like Lego all right
and because it's another thing kind of
thing you can repeat you can add things
to that and then you can take those
things and add things to that and make
bigger and bigger bigger things so here
is a web part called path and it checks
the path and if it works
it succeeds and if it doesn't it fails
okay so there's success or failure if it
matches or it doesn't match and then
here is a thing called okay that's a web
part and all it does is set the sponsor
that all
works okay now if you take two of those
things in you glue them together you
check the path and if the path matches
hello then you return hello okay so
we're just going to glue this two things
together and now we get a new web part
so now we have a web part that matches
the path and returns something okay so
that's a new web part and there's
another one called choose and a choose
web part takes a bunch of these things
and it picks the first one that works
all right so all it does is pick the
first one that works and that whatever
turns it okay
so for example we could say choose
between these two things if the path is
hello return okay hello if the path is
goodbye return okay goodbye so if the
path is goodbye the first one's going to
fail and the second one's going to
succeed if the path is hello are the
first ones - the seed if the path is
neither those the whole thing's going to
fail so the choose itself is going to
fail it's going to be the bad side of
the output okay and then we have a web
part called get which only succeeds if
the request is a get request and then we
can take that get and we can connect it
to the choose and now what we have is
something that will only succeed if it's
a get request and if it's one of those
two paths all right so now we've built
up a more complex thing and we can build
up a complete web app the same way so we
say if it's a get choose between these
paths if it's a post choose between
these paths okay
and then we just assign that whole thing
we choose between the gate and the post
and now we have a complete web app so
this web app is obviously it's a really
simple really simple web app but I mean
it's a web app there's no objects it's
all functions composed together and we
just say start the web server with that
app and then your so the web parts are
connected and they're reusable just like
the Lego so it's a really nice way of
doing web design because each of these
things is testable in isolation you
don't have to set up a whole complicated
server to test this thing each part is
individual there's no strings attached
so each part is testable individually so
this is what a web app looks like in you
have your request coming in you have all
digital functions you choose between
which one based on you don't really have
a route or a dispatch you just have
these juice
webparts okay no classes no loops just
pure functions just composition just
input and output the power of
composition right so let's just look at
what we covered philosophy of
composition always connectable no
adapters needed reusable parts we looked
at principles composable functions and
composable types
everything's composable and the final
composition types of composition we
looked at basic composition just gluing
track together with that we looked at
piping we looked at partial application
we looked at monads yuck
we neither to bind and we looked at
supplies the composition so that really
is everything if you if you understand
this talk which you can always go and
review it later on the video but this is
really everything you need to know about
functional programming right here if you
understand this you know you really
there's nothing stopping you going ahead
and doing stuff so thanks very much this
talk will be on my website F sharp on
the profits there'll be a slides there I
have other videos there I have books
including my domain modeling book and if
you want to contact me on Twitter and
it's got the Russian so thank you very
much
[Applause]